it is well enough that people of the nation do
not understand our banking and monetary system
for if they did i believe there would
be a revolution before tomorrow morning
the only real mistake is the
one from which we learn nothing
anyone who stops learning is old whether at
20 or 80 anyone who keeps learning stays young
the greatest thing in life
is to keep your mind young
thinking is the hardest work there is which
is probably the reason why so few engage in it
coming together is a beginning keeping together
is progress working together is success
there is no man living that cannot
do more than he thinks he can
enthusiasm is the east that makes
your hopes shine to the stars
when everything seems to be going against you
remember that the airplane takes
off against the wind not with it
nothing is particularly hard if
you divide it into small jobs
if money is your hope for independence you
will never have it the only real security
that a man will have in this world is a
reserve of knowledge experience and ability
failure is simply the opportunity to
begin again this time more intelligently
the whole secret of a successful life is to find
out what is one's destiny to do and then do it
if you always do what you've always done
you'll always get what you've always got
competition is the key cutting edge of
business always shaving away at costs
one of the greatest discoveries a man makes
one of his great surprises is to find he
can do what he was afraid he couldn't do
if you think you can do a thing or
think you can't do a thing you're right
a business that makes nothing
but money is a poor business
obstacles are those frightful things you
see when you take your eyes off your goal
education is preeminently a
matter of quality not amount
the short successes that can be gained in a brief
time and without difficulty are not worth much
the competitor to be feared is
one who never bothers about you
at all but goes on making his
own business better all the time
the genius of the american people is self-reliance
america is not a land of money but of wealth not
a land of rich people but of successful workers
greatest thing we can produce is character
everything else can be taken
from us but not our character
the unhappiest man on earth is
the one who has nothing to do
a nation that knows how to work will never suffer
you